I want to go back to it came back to me  the point that you were making about  Elon um and it's like okay we're making  a little bit of progress right baby  steps but I also think it is important  and I'm sure you guys have have talked  about this but I think it's very  important for people to remember because  there are a lot of people on the right  who they're like the the nerdy kid at  the dance they're like oh my God someone  finally likes us please yes invite me to  the dance and it's like he's not I would  not say he's with you on all things  we'll take the win when we can get it  right but like he's a transhumanist he's  a big you know uh climate change guy  like let's  progress is progress let's take baby  steps we'll take the wins where we can  but like don't get too trusting in just  this one guy like he's going to be your  savior I